what's up everybody and welcome back to
the anything better podcast with your
hosts paul versi bill burr uh producer
extraordinaire the greek freak andrew
femless out there in beverly hills got a
quick announcement before we start this
episode guess what everybody oh yeah you
guys asked for it it's getting chilly
the fall is coming you need those new
shirts you need those sweatshirts all
that [ __ ] well that's right by the time
this podcast comes out the official
anything better merchandise shop will be
available you can get your tie-dyed
shirts hoodies halloween [ __ ] it's gonna
be fun so go to the link on the bottom
of this [ __ ] and get it okay that's it
you've been waiting for it people been
asking me all the time when can i get a
big truck electric when can i get the
the halloween [ __ ] it's all coming
now
that that's out of the way you guys are
listening to another episode weird
number
37 and i only had one off the top of my
head somebody gave me another one rodney
harrison of the new england patriots was
37 i believe
um and somebody said sean alexander the
running back of the uh seahawks those
are the only 37s that i know bill what
do you got i got lester hayes
oh
lester hayes mr stickham
two times super bowl champion super bowl
15 16 and 18. mr stickham is done mr
stickham and then also dope one someone
i heard of but i didn't know much from
doke walker
his number's retired by the lions he's
in the ncaa hall of fame the nfl hall of
fame he won two nfl titles that they
don't count for some [ __ ] reason in
1952 and 1953 and paul you know this i
need to tell you this they beat the
cleveland browns beat otto graham the
original tom brady and paul brown the
original bill belichick his name is doke
d-o-k-e d-o-k no d-o-a-k doke walker wow
white guy looks like uh paul horning
all right the best nhl guy to wear it
i'm a bruins fan i'm gonna go with
patrice bergeron
major league baseball paul the best 37 i
could find out there on the internet was
dave steve
the ace for the toronto blue jays wow
back to back blue jays
remember um in nba you got meta world
peace on the lakers
and to go deep paul a deep cut you got
nick van exel
nick on the golden state warriors after
he said i'm we're going singing uh going
back to jamaica remember that when the
lakers got bounced out
was singing come back to jamaica when he
was walking off the court
they were like oh no you ain't doing
that
take that [ __ ] up to oakland he said i
will
we're number 37 and get mentioned on the
anything better podcast
i'm telling you 37 38 even 39. until we
get to the 40s it's weird weird numbers
man
weird numbers uh
somebody asked me what my number would
be
and uh so if we've never mentioned it
before i'd be 11. i was born 11 11. uh i
love the way the two ones look next to
it i always loved how it looked on phil
sims so i would be uh i would be number
i'd be number 11. uh if i was a
defensive back i'd pick one of my kids
uh you know lucas is 29
so maybe something like that so 29 is a
good number raymond claiborne i think
wore that
my first number was 27 on when i played
for the
the raiders was my first team very
soon i was 25 for like two weeks
before my dad was just like christian
knocking your brains out of your [ __ ]
head
that was the end of it
um
that was the end of it i still [ __ ] up
in school
uh you need this you need to focus on
your studies
you didn't do that either
no he thought if he took away everything
i had to look forward to i would somehow
study do better in school
that's how that generation thought paul
that generation yelled at babies okay so
you mean
i don't know what to tell you hey knock
it off
um to a baby baby just sitting there
what the [ __ ]
that baby was me
screaming at a baby the visual the
visual
of a drunk grown man screaming at an
infant's face when i was a kid i used to
see dads yelling at babies like they cut
him off in traffic i mean it was just
[ __ ] it was insane
everyone was doing it you had a station
wagon he had like a pipe and a little
[ __ ]
hat
it just [ __ ] it looked normal you
ever see a family fighting at a
restaurant and they're just quiet it's
[ __ ] horrible
yeah dude i saw
i saw there was a lot of guys coming
home in company cars
and the whole energy in the front yard
of kids playing changed when that
[ __ ]
lincoln town car pulled up or the
[ __ ] you know maybe you only got the
delta 88
and the guy across the street got the
lincoln town car and his wife's titties
were a little bigger i mean tensions
happen the squirt gun fight ended
quickly
the the when you're down
apples cleaning them up when your dad
comes home
i remember being with friends and they'd
be like dude my dad's coming it was it
was like
you just go back to darth vader when the
ship came everybody just was like
dude when dad pulled up it was like
oh dude it was [ __ ] up man
no not like that now it's not like that
oh you you knew what his car sounded
like
coming down the [ __ ] street you ran
to the back of the house
that's why so many guys in your
generation no cars
i used to run away i would literally my
dad pulled in the driveway i ran away
literally ran into the woods
oh jeez
ran for cover
he's back
[Music]
[Laughter]
now now our kids love it when it's us
i know my guy no they're afraid of the
mom the mom's the one you don't want to
[ __ ] with mom comes home it
yeah it just becomes like oh [ __ ] i hope
she's in a good mood
i saw you with your kids and i know you
see me with my kids we we're like when
vito corleone was in the garden playing
with fruit with with the before he
collapsed remember he's just like my
kids like jump on me like i'm not a
person
yeah like if i'm laying i was laying
there the other day i was i had my eyes
closed i was laying on the ground and my
daughter thinks it's the funniest thing
ever to jump up in the air and do hulk
hogan's finishing move
right on the center of my chest now if
i'm ready i can sustain it but i was
completely relaxed i thought she broke
my sternum
and i just went like oh
does she nail it does she nail the kick
the drop
no no dude she just jumps up in the air
and lands ass first on me but you know
she weighs like you know 40 50 pounds
would you want to be at the gym and have
somebody drop a 40-50 pound medicine
ball on your run off the bed
[Laughter]
it's off the playpen
[Music]
no
it's funny they're afraid of mom
lucas came in the other day
and my son is crushing matt my son is
good at hard things
but like a quick little english thing
he's just like ah the english thing was
a little and i'm like dude you got a
hundred on the hardest math test that
everybody in your class failed but
english is an issue whatever and he just
goes as they're walking in the house he
goes
dude you're going to tell mom or should
i tell mom you think she's going to
freak out and i'm like no you're
crushing school just go in and tell her
that you had a hard time at one thing in
english or whatever and he was just like
he walked in the door
and if it was me i'm like you know
like you know rodney in back to school
abc you're in a top three yeah
yeah it takes a lot um
it takes a lot
for me to get upset with my
you know only today i had to be a little
stern with my son because his new things
he grabs his sister's hair
with that hulk vice grip that he has
i just had to be like no you can't do
that you can't do that nice nice hands
all right and he was just staring at me
and i had to stare him down
because his [ __ ] is he just looks back
at you
like he's just observing
i told you that stuff like his thing
when i go to give him a bath
the second the water gets in the tub he
just starts grabbing [ __ ] and throws it
in the tub he knows he's not supposed to
like he grabs the bath mat
the second there's a you you're not
looking he just grabs it and he just
throws it in and then he just looks at
you
uh and then i just start
laughing i can't stop laughing and then
it's worse then he's like oh this is a
good thing yeah he just starts throwing
everything in the tub
but you know you know i have to
basically everything has to be in the
sink so he can't reach it or whatever
whatever's not in the sink he throws in
the tub
oh my god dude that's [ __ ] so funny
though yeah just then he gets in it and
then he brings his hands back like this
and he just goes wham he gets the water
all over me i go you know the guys go
what are you doing or whatever and then
he cracks up and then i laugh and then
he does it more this is no respect
there's no respect i'm i'm
overcompensating paul i'm
overcompensating for having to run into
the woods when my dad came
dude i literally ran into the woods
it was like a lion was coming and we
were all gazelles and we just got off
the [ __ ] serengeti you stopped me
looking
yup oh man
you know what's weird i don't remember
my dad coming home my dad was five when
they got divorced so my memory is my dad
just pulling up in a [ __ ] dope whip
and we would just get in the car and go
out with him
like he p my dad had a 1982 brand new
black
jaguar xj6 1982
and you know it had the it had the
jaguar on the front hood the hood
ornament yeah and uh and it was white
leather inside he's a version of course
he got white leather inside and uh he
would just pull up you know and it
wasn't 100 sicilian guy is going to go
with the white leather interior
it's it's you're going to look like a
olive skin against it you're going to
look like a god
i don't know how somebody doesn't love
it
i if i got in that car i would look like
that reverse beatles album you know
where it was all black just their heads
it would be all white and just my orange
beard and my blue eyes where'd he go
what's your go-to interior you go you
are you like the like the red or the tan
what's your go-to well what year are we
talking paul
i'm just saying like i'll tell you this
so wimbledon i'm a ford guy a wimbledon
white ford
with that that ford blue interior okay
forget about it i love the red interior
too but i mean that's just sort of like
a hat on a hat with me i'm orange i
don't think the red's gonna look good
but uh i liked um
ford literally had like one that was
called um
something like window block box green
something about plants
and there was a buddy of mine his dad
had like a 76
ford f-250 high boy like an original
with the transfer case you know
separated from the uh transmission
so um he had that thing
snow plowed that thing forever
he was like 12 years old and i think
about it now i want to say it was a 76
it might have been a 70. but i was just
thinking like i would buy that truck off
him if he still had if it wasn't rusted
out
um you know my ultimate car collection
poll is just basically a bunch of ford
trucks
i would have the 68 ford f-100 that i
have
i'd have like a 76 77
high boy
uh f250
and then i would have a
like a 85 or an
86 f-150 4x4 short bed xlt lariat
and then i would also have an 80 to 86
somewhere in there four-wheel drive ford
bronco two-tone
i did a movie recently and when the main
character had a blue and white one and i
was just like wow
that is [ __ ] awesome
yeah um
my grandfather rest to soul
he had a brown car and i never
understood why until now
my dream what i want now is i want
a dark chocolate brown car with all
white leather inside and wood to match
these oh that's over chocolate brown you
can't have [ __ ] brown you gotta turn it
off with brown dark like almost like at
night you don't know if it's black but
in the day it's dark chocolate brown
and it's got white inside it's
one of the most beautiful it's it's
incredible um but dude i was thinking
about you laughing at me
so we got this microsoft flight
simulator for for for boeing jets right
and
lucas is and it's all like the airport's
exactly the approach
and then they have a famous airports
that are hard to land in france and all
this [ __ ] so i got the headset on i got
the [ __ ] thing and i'm sitting there
my heart's jacked [ __ ] and you hear
the woman's voice landing gear landing
gear right [ __ ] like dude i had a
[ __ ] anxiety attack during this thing
i had an anxiety attack i was thinking i
was good dude here's what i learned
here's what i learned about me
you never want me flying an airplane
ever
[ __ ] bill i had a i had a a
747 that i needed to land and they took
me on final approach to jfk the real way
i had all the instruments i had
everything there
i did probably read the instruments did
you slow down you still know
500 miles an hour no i learned about
flare for people that don't know what
flare is flare is when the plane is
coming in for final approach to touch
you got to lift the nose a little bit
that's what they call flare all right
and obviously lower the lower the
[ __ ] engines down so i had to i so
i'm like down don't you have to bring i
don't know anything about planes don't
you bring your flaps down or something
like that too yeah the the you have the
the what's it called what are they
called the rudders that go each way but
once you level i'm talking about like
the last thousand feet
you basically the last thousand feet
you're just coming in they obviously
want you to line up with the [ __ ]
runway and have it level and then when
you're about to approach when you're
about to touch you gotta [ __ ] pull
back on the engines and do what they say
flare so the nose doesn't go down and
then it just basically goes dude i
crashed this [ __ ] thing
it just the screen went black and i was
just dude i was having anxiety doing it
now did you see they they have they
probably have runway lights there
yeah
or a papi and it's just like all white
you're too high all red you're dead
you something like red under white
you're all right something like that
helicopters don't have to deal with that
because you can do like a steep approach
we can stop and do all of that [ __ ] so i
always forget how those things work
so then i did a cessna and she goes okay
what we're gonna do is i want you to
taxi out turn and stop and wait to take
off i [ __ ] went past it onto the
grass i couldn't even turn dude i
couldn't even that's how like realistic
it was that turning the sticks and
touching everything and i was like look
i just can't do this no but you got to
learn how to do it i think if you double
tap your stopping i had to learn all of
that
you know
when i started doing instrument [ __ ] was
i had to learn how to
basically you know on that simulator fly
like a uh
just like a twin i was flying a twin
whatever the hell you call him and uh i
remember was just as you were taking off
you had to have like left rudder so it
would stay
um
pointed straight or whatever once i got
in the air i was kind of fine
but um it's fun dude doing that [ __ ] is
a lot of fun well that's my fan i have
two fantasies
one is uh robbing a bank
i always wanted to do rob i always
wanted to rob a bank and
two is i'm on an airplane and the flight
attendant comes screaming out saying is
there somebody that could fly a plane
and it's all over and i [ __ ] get in
there in my [ __ ] jordan threes and my
hoodie and i [ __ ] put the thing on
and i take us home and everybody and i'm
a [ __ ] you know so at least in my
mind what if you rob a bank you take
hostages and then you demand a plane and
they give you pilots
and then they want the pilots to fly
where they can arrest you and then you
tell them to get the [ __ ] out because
you know how to fly you go under the
radar and you fly somewhere else and you
leave with the money and they never
catch you
that would be [ __ ] dope man remember
that guy that jumped out of a plane he
robbed there was a guy that like oh yeah
that guy who died did he die well they
never found him but yeah they he [ __ ]
died you can't jump out of a [ __ ]
dc-10 and live
with money
37 000. yeah [ __ ] 3 200 in quarters
[ __ ] dragging you down on the ground
dude i got a i got a i had a screenplay
idea
bank robbers you never seen this before
bank robbers who kill everybody
so if you just they just go in and they
spray because they know the code there's
no it's not oh we have this amount of
time they go and they kill everybody but
one day they're about to go in one of
the guys sees his wife
going in with one of his kids
and the rules are everybody dies and
he's got to try to stop it and then
that's where i ended up ending with the
idea
so it's really needs to be flushed my
thing is why do i give a [ __ ] about
those guys if they just go and shoot
people
[ __ ] them
yeah i didn't get that far
i got to figure out a subplot well if
you're going to do an anti-hero movie i
think you got a great start off point
[Laughter]
if you notice in those kinds of movies
when they have somebody just killing
everybody it's always unsightly people
well they just show them for half a
second they don't want you to get into
their backstory that this is these are
people that people love
you know what i mean like they always
got to be like a dick that's why like in
all those stephen cigar movies
like he couldn't just walk in and beat
the [ __ ] out of somebody and be a bully
somebody had to [ __ ] with him you know
like hey nice ponytail there twinkle
toes
yeah and then he could turn
and then he kicked the [ __ ] out of him
every single time every single time
there was always that guy who couldn't
just drink his drink he just had to go
out of his [ __ ] way to get this [ __ ]
kicked out of him and the whole purpose
of the scene is to establish what we
already know
that is steven seagal knows karate
yeah right
which by the way speaking of karate
uh the heroes and icon channel how great
a name is that
is gonna start rerunning all the walker
texas rangers
with chuck norris and chuck norris has
one where he's facing off with somebody
and the guy gets into some sort of
stance he goes ah another karate guy
because i think he was a kung fu guy and
he does a spin and heel kick a lot joe
rogan with cowboy boots on
so as bad as it would be to catch joe
rogan's heel just imagine it's chuck
norris's heel
and it's in a cowboy boot
which you know has a manly high heel on
it i never saw one episode of walker
texas ranger have you
no that's why i want to watch it
because i feel like um
all the snarky douches
killed off that sort of manliness on
television you know he's singing
huh
he thinks he sings the theme song sorry
i mean that's awesome wait who does
chuck
yeah yeah it's like yeah it starts off
in the eyes of a ranger and then he's
he's kind of like he talk talks a little
first and then he starts singing yeah
the chords that's a man who was in the
business long enough
and found out that if he sang the song
every time they play the episode he's
getting paid
that guy never had to buy another ghee
for the rest of his life after that gig
and then he had that that [ __ ] thing
that brought you up and down the the
slide
remember that and he would sit there
with his red chest hair just [ __ ]
looking all shredded at like 80 or
whatever the hell he was oh he did those
come on sometimes late night you almost
buy one of those
yeah he did those commercials with
christy brinkley and i always thought
something was going on with them during
the thing which you know i was like ah
something i like you know chucky may be
taking that down she was divorced at the
time remember body by jake
the guy from bachelor party man he
crushed it in bachelor party then all of
a sudden he was just body by jake i bet
he made way more money selling that [ __ ]
than he did in the movie with the
residuals guaranteed he did it i always
love when i see people
that used to be acting or whatever and
then they branched off like
what's-her-face uh suzanne summers all
of a sudden she had the thigh master i'm
like there you go what about joshua
dude joe piscopo got [ __ ] jacked he
was [ __ ] jacked yeah he did
yeah he got he got
he was foreshadowing what was going to
happen in baseball
he was he was like 10 12 years ah he was
before maguire
yeah he what funny would that be if they
asked mark maguire how did you get into
steroids you know i was a joe piscopo
fan you know the guy
i mean his first special yeah i mean it
was funny but the next spell she came
out he just [ __ ] grabbed a microphone
his [ __ ] veins
dude i think that that's such a gross
thing when dudes have that vein that
that wiggly vein in their neck and their
just their neck just
starts at their jaw and it just comes
out
who wants to look like that i would
never want to look like that i would
love to know what the high of being on
roids feels like i don't think it's roid
rage i think you're just so excited you
want to show off
just pick up a refrigerator
no dude those guys are angry man i knew
dudes that like those dudes [ __ ]
freak out at nothing
yeah but that was that was the old [ __ ]
dude that was the [ __ ] from when we were
coming up when it was like [ __ ] horse
tranquilizers
and a little bit of cocaine or something
i don't know
look at saint bernard's dick all [ __ ]
mashed up and you just shot it into your
butt cheek
just came out frothing at the mouth just
throwing kettlebells there was no
kettlebells back then
no acne i had friends that get acne and
you just when they put a t-shirt on and
you were just like oh dude i do not want
to get oh yeah and they had those giant
lats
like they looked like doors to get into
a castle and then they had like the
skinny [ __ ] legs because i don't
think i don't think anybody did a squat
in the 80s
they had their big puffy pants and they
would come in and they would wiggle into
their [ __ ] old cutlass so they're
monte carlo or the buick regal with the
t-tops
they would come in and they had the
[ __ ] the wrap-around shades
you know and some peroxide blonde was
always sitting there who wasn't really
that hot
she was just in shape and dyed her hair
blonde remember those chicks oh my god
it's just like if you just you know
let your hair go brown you'd look like
me
that could have been me in the passenger
seat
my uh
my dad had a buick regal i remember a
buddy of mine in high school
i was always friends with older people
my whole life older kids wanted to hang
with me always
and i was whether it would be a grade or
two up i don't know why
and uh because you could grow a beard in
the eighth grade paul
probably
and uh
we're in this
yeah this was me in seventh this is me
the way i look now in math i know
dude you do three days on the road
paul's torso has a five o'clock shadow
no dude if i let it go but i use all
that [ __ ] to shave it down um
if
so we decided to get in my friend's
buick regal and go to new york city we
just cut school
and we packed it five of us two in the
front three in the back
and doing the dumbest [ __ ] like oh yeah
i was gonna say that in the house soon
before the cops pulled you over no
five [ __ ] heads in a buick in the middle
of a school day yeah we put in wu-tang
thinking we're cool we're flying down
the west side highway listen cash rules
everything around
creep get your money
[Music]
and we just went to a place to grab
beers like we didn't even do it right
like we went down to new york city and
then bought either cans of beers or 40s
and like tried to like drink them quick
and then but here's where it got [ __ ]
up dude that sounds [ __ ] awesome yeah
it was it was i would do that now
and yeah and here's the thing though we
picked up a hitchhiker
and in return
where did he sit
he gave he gave weed uh he sat in the
back he sat in the back with us and we
just drove him up a little bit off an
egg so there's four in the back
now on the way two in the front and now
there's drugs in the car all right now
there's four of us and then we pick up a
hitchhiker thanks a lot man here and
gives us
whether it was weed or hash whatever it
was i think it was a bag of weed
we go back to my buddy's [ __ ] house
to drink beers and i hit this thing
and i stared
i stared at the floor in the kitchen for
what i didn't know was either a minute
or two hours i didn't know
and i looked up and the pattern of the
floor was on my friend's face and i
[ __ ] freaked out dude i tr i [ __ ]
freaked out i start breathing heavy dude
i'm laying on the couch i think i'm
having a heart attack and he's going
dude you got it you're gonna be all
right bad feeling about this one man my
heart is just jacked up they're trying
to calm me down i'm freaking out dude
i'm crawling out of my skin
and then i realized yeah we took drugs
off of a complete stranger in new york
city
i don't know what the thing was laced
with but
i'm glad it happened because i don't do
drugs
i it made me afraid
you know i my friends would trip on acid
every day i had friends that would trip
on acid every day
and
i never did it one time one time they
were like hey dude here's a white pearl
we were at a friend's house on a
saturday called it a white pearl
and uh i went like this and i just i
[ __ ] i got i freaked out i put on my
tongue for a second i freaked out spit
it out
not big on drugs so you wasted it
yeah well i did the right thing
i don't know paul
you know so there's a whole big argument
now coming back around that whole say no
to drugs was maybe a wrong thing
i think do you say yes to drugs
no then you see how it makes you feel
and you see how far you can dig the
whole pole
yeah and still crawl out and rebuild it
because if you don't then what what what
is your autobiography going to be it's
going to be like what eight pages long
no this guy takes from drugs and i uh
enjoyed coffee cake with a cappuccino
yeah this guy crushed it in white
leather cars
and he got the girls magazine at uh
the bookstore and then there i saw her
with her corduroy pants
i'm not fornicate until we were married
no i'm not advocating drugs and i don't
like that [ __ ] that everybody's talking
like when you do psychedelic [ __ ]
you like
like
when you see things that opens up a new
world it's like what does that mean like
what is it i'll tell you paul i took i
took mushrooms and i've been sober ever
since because i understood that it was
in this uh
i understood this feeling that i've been
carrying my whole life that i never even
noticed was there but were you in
another world or no
was it like i was in a whole new world i
was tripping on mushrooms
yeah i said i can't [ __ ] relate
that's the one thing i wish i could
relate i don't know but it sounds
[ __ ] scary no it was like i was in
this there was this feeling
and there was it wasn't like
hostile it just was
and there was no out running it there
was no walking away from it it just
undeniably
was
wow and i couldn't ignore it and i had
to face it and be like what is this
and i i offered a couple of different
answers and the thing was like that's
not it
that's not it and then i was like oh
this is how i felt growing up that's it
and i was like oh
what
this this is like what i need to deal
with i need to be sober and i need to
figure out
what you know and dude and i'm telling
you
after that [ __ ] within two days i knew
exactly who i was as a person and why i
did stand up i knew everything that i
did in my life why i did it good or bad
helping people hurting people
[ __ ] [ __ ] up
the way i the reason why i drank the way
i drank i knew every [ __ ] uh bit of
it
so there are certain ones you know that
was my experience paul
i love how andrew's in the back just
going like in complete understanding
he's like yeah no that's right that's it
yeah no like but bill says i mean
listening to people talk about this can
usually be insufferable but bill's
bill's nailing it like that's just very
simply that's what it is it kind of just
washes away a lot of you don't get the
trip you want paul you get the trip you
need man
that's what
jesus nah now [ __ ] that man yeah that
sounds no i [ __ ] hate like i used to
do a bit about is there anything worse
than
listening to somebody dumb that took
mushrooms and then you got to listen to
them like they figured some [ __ ] out and
it's just like no man you were just in
an altered like that when though you
know some i don't like listening to
people that tripped and like i [ __ ]
saw god man
and like the clouds open up and i was
like whoa and the thing was like come on
man and i was like you know me i was
like [ __ ] man i think half of it is
people just make this [ __ ] up
um
but i watched this i watched this video
um about
them using low levels of um
micro dosing
yeah like mushrooms or like um
ecstasy
is part of therapy
for p people that to treat uh ptsd
um
for like you know it was over in israel
and one guy one of the cases
there was a terrorist attack some
[ __ ] [ __ ] blew up a bus full of
people and this guy was one of the first
people that ran up and it was just all
body parts and [ __ ] and he was just some
regular dude and he just had saw that
totally [ __ ] him up there was another
woman who got kidnapped and she thought
she was gonna get killed and raped they
ended up letting her go there was
another one that this dude got molested
by his dad
so all of them had these [ __ ] things
and and like like the they were on this
trajectory that moment happened it's
like a bend in the airway they just went
in a different [ __ ] course so then
they took this [ __ ]
and you know uh because i think
it was trying to undo
like that shock where you just block it
out and then you just like i blocked it
out i'm not feeling it and you're just
carrying it with you and it's affecting
all of these decisions so they in an
experimental way
are are using this
this stuff so those cases that they
showed
um
they were claiming that it had a
positive effect and then they said that
80 of them some really high number it
had a positive effect so i i don't know
all i know is i only did it one time
and that's kind of uh
[Music]
you know what oh i think i needed i kind
of felt like in the last like week that
maybe i needed to do it again
like every once in a while almost like
do it again to be like all right let's
see where that feeling is now
um
but like you know
but it's fun to get there you know look
like the [ __ ]
you know inanimate [ __ ] was breathing i
was like
like the whole [ __ ] place was doing
this it was just
i would have a [ __ ] full-fledged past
i can't handle [ __ ] i'm a [ __ ] when it
comes to [ __ ] like that
how about dude
you know so you got to be like you just
[ __ ] roll with it you just don't sit
there trying to fight it's a guy yeah
but it's like you're [ __ ] going like
oh my god is the chair alive like you're
in some high school film strip
trying to scare kids you just look at it
like oh the chair looks like it's
breathing because i'm tripping on
mushrooms you don't forget that you took
mushrooms
me one thing dude if you like
you just forgot
if somebody slipped this [ __ ] into your
drink and all of a sudden you're walking
around and [ __ ] started doing that but
even then you'd think like okay
obviously i somehow ingested something
because i know this isn't you you know
it isn't real as it's happening well you
know what you call me paulie you call me
pauly positives and i think that's why i
tampered with uh you know little eight
ball corner pocket to me is number one
that's why i just can't which is insane
because that is like the most evil
[ __ ] drug
ever and like i've never seen anybody on
coke who was cool ever
all you want to do is get the [ __ ] away
from him and if you're doing blow with
him all you're doing is watching to make
sure he's not doing all of it i mean
dude that [ __ ] there's like different
drugs dude
like that that drug is on that drug is
on the other side of the tracks don't go
into that neighborhood
i will tell you this one time i saw this
[ __ ] guy i don't know what he was
high on
i was on 23rd in broadway right by the
flatiron building and it was one of
those [ __ ]
freezing cold new york city days where
you know where the wind is just whipping
through the buildings so it's it's
already like five degrees out and then
with the wind it goes down to like -15
and i don't give a [ __ ] how many layers
you have on it goes right to your bone
and you're si we were sitting there
waiting for the light to change
and i'm just sitting you know [ __ ]
[ __ ] let's [ __ ] go you
literally want to run home
and i hear this guy
just crying laughing
and i look over and there's this guy in
a [ __ ] jeans and t-shirts
and he is crying laughing
and he's like not even there
it's like whatever he's experiencing he
was just crying [ __ ] laughing he was
laughing so hard it started making me
laugh even though i was freezing my ass
off and i always wondered what he was on
yeah and i was like as much as that's
[ __ ] his life up like that experience
of that
is a very rare thing i mean that sounds
like weed or edibles to me i mean no
dude
no this guy was like this guy was
tripping he was like
he was seeing [ __ ]
it was like there was somebody talking
to him
telling him the funniest story ever
and like dude he was standing and he was
turning so he's like he was like
i can't even do the laugh it was it was
a pure joy
it was like a high school cafeteria
laugh
where everybody's just pouting the table
and you wonder if you're ever gonna
laugh like that again he was doing it by
himself
in like minus 15 degree weather in a
t-shirt and jeans and we're all sitting
there freezing our [ __ ] asses off
waiting for the light to turn and i was
just sitting there going like it was one
of the few times
like i ever saw something and i was just
going well maybe drugs aren't bad
i mean i don't think i've ever i haven't
enjoyed a summer the way this guy's
enjoying the [ __ ] winter here
with no jacket
yeah yeah that that sounds like some
some next [ __ ] man
yeah those are the best those laughs
those those laughs add to your life my
dad took me and christian to see rodney
dangerfield at radio city and i don't
know how they allowed me in there but i
was sleeping on my dad's lap but by the
end of it it's true
and my dad was laughing so hard at
another guy laughing at rodney so he
said rodney was killing so hard that the
guy would laugh so hard at a joke and
then try to catch his breath to get the
next joke but like could it and my dad
was in the balcony at radio city
watching this guy and my dad still says
as great as the show was that guy
laughing at him made his night
yeah like watching somebody cry laughing
like watching somebody truly
truly cry one that i remember that i
laughed at patrice o'neil rest his soul
and that guy was in opie and anthony
and they were saying stuff and he would
make his dick oh the up and down game
yeah the up and down game he says
something about the mets and his dick
would just go up and then go dude when
patrice started [ __ ] like he started
out like like a police siren and he just
had to walk out when i watched that
laugh i literally almost started to
hysterical
when you catch one like that it's
incredible
it's like a laugh like that is
is incredible i know you said you had
one at a funeral
uh yeah
yeah i had one my buddy's dad died and
uh
it was pouring down raining
so they had one of those stupid home
depot little [ __ ] force things with
the tent top and it was just too many
people because the guy was so beloved so
we were standing in there and there was
no way to get underneath it so we were
you know getting rained on
and my buddy was just inside of it
and for some reason the rain was coming
down so hard it created like this river
and it was just missing my buddy's coat
and in the middle of them like blowing
them into the ground my buddy just was
standing there to break the tension and
the sadness reached up and just grabbed
it
and leaned it over so when my body had
like it wasn't like suede
it was just that that faux whatever
horseshit like letterman jacket you know
and then the fake leather sleeves he had
a jacket like that on okay yeah and it
went down his [ __ ] back and we
started laughing
because it broke the tension and then we
were also like oh my god we're laughing
at a funeral so i just remember looking
away and seeing one of like the guys
that was driving the casket one of those
[ __ ] guys was just standing there
looking at us
like what the [ __ ]
oh um yeah i had one of those i had
another one one time
a long time ago i was hanging out with a
buddy of mine he was uh he like always
looked up when he [ __ ] talked like he
really [ __ ] insecure like hey man
like you know what's going on
so
we were drinking in faneuil hall it was
like last call we were trying to get
something else to drink and we were just
[ __ ] wasted
and we were hanging out and then this
older black guy came up he was dressed
in a suit and he had this briefcase
so my friend's like he's like uh
he's like hey man like you know what's
with the briefcase
and the black guy was like i got my
papers in there man he goes you always
got to be ready to make a move something
like that and then my buddy just goes
we'll go ahead and make a move man
because i'll [ __ ] kill you
like he took it the wrong way because
they were both high and drunk or
whatever and they both
like
started squaring off and the bartender
like lunged between them and i was
crying laughing because i was like
that's like a perfect like sitcom joke
like just when you just totally like
misunderstand somebody and i i was like
i couldn't believe it happened
and then i was also like laughing
because the guy was like 60. but he was
in his she was like an old time [ __ ]
you know yeah hustle looking guy and
then my buddies all like all [ __ ]
beer and waterlogged
um
that was one of those ones i was i there
was that one like when i was just
yeah i was laughing so hard i couldn't
even try to break up the fight or
explain like no no he meant business
move
can't make you move man cause i'll
[ __ ] kill you
i had one at the soho cigar lounge where
i i actually feared for my health i
begged i begged him to i don't know what
happened but it's with a buddy and he
was talking about colonoscopies
and he's dude we're smoking we're having
a picture of this we're having a great
time i mean great time i got to dab it
off nicaraguan i got some sort i think i
got either lagavulin or lafroid10 i'm
having a [ __ ] great time and we're
sitting there and we start talking about
men's health
and dude he got so serious and he's
going no no paul paul it's not 50
anymore okay it's not 50 anymore it's
40. you got to get a colonoscopy dude
they're finding this stuff like that and
he starts telling me all this stuff and
just out of nowhere the way he did he
goes with all seriousness he just goes
he goes have you ever have you had your
[ __ ] checked dude the way he said it
though
dude i don't i can't even he just goes
have you had your [ __ ] checked dude
he said it with and i
[ __ ] lost control of myself i said
the sincerity of that and then he starts
laughing i'm holding my stomach and then
you know when it just comes on i'm
holding because you're talking about
have you had your [ __ ] checked dude
and and i go no i don't ah i'm just
going stop
stop and i could not breathe and people
were just looking at our booth i'm
pounding it i'm pounding it it was i
just lost control of myself dude i had
one with you that time when we were
doing that gig in maine
and that guy came out and we thought he
was dressed as elvis we thought he was a
fat elvis and it turned out he was just
dressed as wolverine and he was just fat
so he's more of a fat wolverine yeah so
he came out and he was talking to us
about whatever the [ __ ] he was dressed
up as and in the middle of talking this
guy just [ __ ] rips a fart
like
like as he was talking to us
like it was nothing
and i remember you were talking to him
when he ripped the fart and i just
turned away
and just like without trying to move my
head or anything just was [ __ ] like
dying laughing
it it went from yeah it went from us
thinking this is going to be a cool hang
and this guy's hilarious
to
he was smoking a shitty cigar he was fat
out of shape he was a slob who was
farting and we wanted nothing yeah he
wasn't elvis he was wolverine it was
horrible
he no longer
i learned that night the difference
between wolverine and fat elvis
it's just you know about 40 pounds
but he didn't even conceal that fart he
didn't even try to i've never seen it it
was [ __ ] gangster he just was like he
had to and he let it go and he didn't
give a [ __ ] if we heard it and he didn't
even break
his it was like watching steve grogan
when the middle linebacker was coming up
and he just waited till the last second
before he let it go he just didn't give
a [ __ ] standing with the train coming
right at
you yeah oh [ __ ] man
that guy was [ __ ] oh he was a mess i
remember the woman he was with i
remember that it was like some halloween
party it was brutal yeah no it was bad
the whole thing was uh you saw a uh it
was just a group of people that never
had a chance
it was funny they just never did that
kind of people you need to hit the
lottery like within 18 months they'd be
broke again and somebody would be
murdered
like they just
they just don't like they just they
didn't have a chance they never had
that's one of the saddest [ __ ] things
when you do the road as a comedian like
the first four years of your career
you are performing for the generally
speaking you were performing in places
where people never had a [ __ ] chance
oh my god and if you can somehow get
through the depression of that
you have a chance
to get to a funny bone or something but
i mean that there was just like
they were [ __ ] people dude
no
i remember oh my god i remember a long
time ago i was [ __ ] um
i was dating this chick
and uh
she sang in this cover band
it's a [ __ ] i don't i can't remember
so [ __ ] long ago
and
afterwards he was sitting at the table
it was around the holidays
and that song grandma got run over by a
reindeer came on
and the whole table of people not her
band just her the fans of the band were
all singing it cracking up laughing like
they thought it was the funniest thing
ever
and i was just looking at them
and i was looking at their dirty
all-white reebok sneakers and i was just
i just saw all of them i was just like
this like it was it's just like i wasn't
judging them i was just this crushing
depression
just washed all over me i was just like
these people
are gonna have kids and and they're
never gonna have a chance
like there is no
this is before american idol paul there
was like no way out of this
the visual of you watching them sing the
song
like at the intensity and hysteria
hysteria that they were in during it is
amazing oh dude it was like these were
people that lived in trailer parks man
and it's just like people don't
understand i don't think people
understand that level of poverty
um where they they do a lot of stuff
about inner cities like non-white people
but white people that live in trailer
parks generally speaking are just
laughed at
so there's not even any empathy for them
and i just remember i had like empathy i
was just looking at them
and i was hearing the smoker's cough and
i was seeing the boils on their faces i
mean they literally looked like they
were from another they were so broke
they look like they were from another
century
oh dude grandma got run over by a
reindeer
and they would laugh every time it came
around
and i was just like oh my god
and then they were looking at me and i
wasn't laughing and they could see me
taking in what their world was and i had
i was only like donny brasco i had to
like [ __ ] fake like oh
no he's funny
oh dude it was like
it was literally like the electric slide
was the most exciting thing that
happened to any of their families for
generations i mean it was just [ __ ]
i don't think that was one of the most
depressed i'd ever been it had i'd ever
been like i was just like there had
there's no reason
why in a first world country people
should have to live like this
whatever books they were given in in in
high school need to be updated
it's tough this song should not bring
this level of [ __ ] humor and joining
people
that's what's making me
oh man
and it's not judging like i'm not trying
to judge but
i had restless leg syndrome i was just
[ __ ] sitting there like i got to get
the [ __ ] out of here no man i just
wanted to just
it's brutal i want to do the irish
goodbye to the relationship too i just
want to be like hang on a second
i have to go to the bathroom and i just
wanted to get in my car
and drive out of maine
back to
where i was living
no dude i remember i went to this place
once and it was so brutal
that like the people in the band were
cool i'm just saying they're fans i'm
talking about i was sitting with their
fans and i was just like
is there anything better than driving
away
is there anything better that's one of
my favorite things to do ever is to
drive away in that movie
that movie uh where ben affleck's wife
fakes her death
yeah gone girl oh yeah yeah yeah gonna
go where did you go gone girl that we've
gone baby yeah yeah yeah yeah when she
drives away and she's eating like snack
foods i thought the whole movie was
[ __ ] up but she's just sitting there
eating like ho ho's driving a shitty car
down the highway remember thinking like
that right there is like the most free
you can ever be just driving away are
you just driving away from whatever it
is
get your food and just drive
can't wait to leave just can't wait
to leave stacy and i went to a place and
we don't want to judge anybody we know
people don't have certain amounts of
money but dude they were bringing out
like hors d'oeuvres and it was just like
cold cuts on paper plates
dude it was i'm not like and you know me
like when it comes to meats and [ __ ]
like you gotta roll it up put it on some
[ __ ] you know
i mean they were they might as well have
taken like
just like baloney out of the thing from
the deli and just [ __ ] slapped it on
a paper plate and like you know those
like shitty cheddar cheese blocks with
like toothpicks it was it was like you
give this [ __ ] to your dog and i
remember just sitting there
and i'm like looking at my wife and i'm
going like we gotta get the [ __ ] out of
here man i gotta get the [ __ ] out of
here like
dude it's sitting there just seeing
people that don't they have no shot in
life
it's sad i mean you can't be a human
being you're not you're just sitting
there you it just it kills you just
looking at them
and like
oh my god you're meeting like [ __ ] 18
year old people that have the teeth of
like a 60 year old
[ __ ] sitting there with a cigarette
danging a lot of them because they don't
know any better it's just like like how
do you end this cycle yeah yeah
it's the
the conversations are brutal it's just
you know oh and then they start picking
up on you looking at them like that
then you got to quickly be like oh hello
i try to play it off
oh no it's brutal man and you don't want
to judge you want to but i agree with
you i think if you give those people
money i don't think it changes
no no you have to
undo like
you have to yeah like that so you you
know hold like they're done they're done
they're cooked it's done you can't do
you have to you what you have to do is
go in
like special ops and take their children
which why would you do that but that's
the only way to break that cycle because
those people
know that cloud hanging over them are
then going to teach those kids there's
just there's no and every once in a
while
there's like the person that [ __ ]
makes it out of there
[Music]
you know what i mean and
i i don't i don't know how they do it i
don't know how the [ __ ] they do it like
uh
wow dude that really just brought back
like some [ __ ] memories of some
one-nighters i did
in like new hampshire
maine upstate new york
um
middle of this country dude just like in
the middle of [ __ ] nowhere the places
where like they dump the nuclear waste
and these people say we don't want it
here and they just don't have the money
to fight it
and these you know you go yeah you're
doing stand up in a city with like a
state where like the [ __ ] life
expectancy is like 48 years old
you know like ben franklin live longer
than half of these [ __ ] people and
what what's sad too is you see their
parents
you see a little boy or girl that's four
or five you see their parents and you're
like you're [ __ ] dude i went to this
[ __ ] like white truck we got to get
off the subject i think we're just we're
killing people here
i saw this one kid he was like four he
had like wild hair he was running around
and me and my buddy joked it was like
dude who's gonna put that kid in the
[ __ ] cage
now seeing people without a chance dude
it's just it's the most depressing thing
you could ever [ __ ] see and then you
try to
like how you can do it how you can stop
it dude it's literally like it's like a
[ __ ] fan blade you try to stick your
hand in you're gonna lose your hand
trying to you just gotta like
[ __ ] just save one
all right that was uplifting
you know what's funny i saw that in
europe too dude
did you oh all these [ __ ] liberals
out here trying every other country is
amazing and this country's so [ __ ] up
dude
i saw that in europe i obviously i saw
other places that i went to that you're
not allowed to say because then you're
being mean to the country but like dude
i've seen levels of [ __ ] poverty
yeah
it just uh yeah it makes you question
god you mean everything you're like i
know there's a devil
like i definitely don't have a doubt
about that but like that there's a god
that gives a [ __ ]
um that makes human beings wired the way
they are
that they can like oppress people and
and just [ __ ] people over
ah dude it's it's uh yeah all right
let's uh let's move on pill let's move
on so
halloween's coming up dude
[Laughter]
what are you going as well i'm psyched i
think the kids can go out with like a
mass because uh two years ago i took my
daughter out and she was so friggin
excited she was so shy the first three
houses
and then when she got candy and they
were all freaking out about her costume
they would open the door and she'd be
down the end of the walk just screaming
i doc mcstuffins you know
and she just like hailed it up and was
like
i mean it really is the greatest night
ever in a lot of ways
a lot of ways it's better than christmas
for a kid it's like
like they're living this fantasy you
just knock door to door and people just
give you free candy yeah parents are
gonna let you have some and not you know
tell you to brush your teeth or whatever
every five seconds or who gave you that
or whatever and it's yours
it's your candy and you get complimented
every door they look great uh oh yeah
yeah it is great it is great and going
with your kids is good
going with your kids is like it brings
it back in a way
you know oh i just watched as long as my
kids are having a good time i don't give
a [ __ ]
as long as they don't end up paul in
those situations like we just [ __ ]
described
i don't like those piece of [ __ ] houses
that keep their lights black
they just [ __ ] they just they just
call it out it's like
you can't go to the store and buy a
[ __ ] couple of uh kid cats you lazy
[ __ ] well no if they're single
and you know they want to go out you
know the chicks horrid up that night you
want to go out and see if they're out
there trying to get laid paul it's not
always that no no i know i'm talking
about the families that are home that
just do the
you know the good ones will leave a
bucket at the end
[Music]
and they just stamp
[ __ ] kids take all the candy
no i respect it paul i respect the light
out
because there's a lot of people that
participate and then they just give you
like the little bite-sized tight [ __ ]
you know candy it's like why don't you
just keep me light out
but this is how you're gonna show up on
the door
and go hey what do you got yeah i go i
give extra too you know me i give extra
i used to do full-size candy bars and
then what happened was these [ __ ]
[ __ ] parents would have their kids
come back again
and then adults would start coming by
and i would just be i remember what time
there was a guy
wow
i [ __ ] pulled in like in his he's
like as old as i was i just go really
he's like yes
i'm like really he goes yes
and i didn't have any more really than
me and i still like candy so i just gave
it to him
i'll never forget that really yes
uh i just give extra you guys want a
little more take a little more plus we
don't get a lot up here so like we get
like a couple of rushes and then we just
have all this extra stuff so the last 10
people that come i just we just load
them up i just load them up get it out
of here yeah get it out i'll tell you
what i used to like as a kid and i just
can't handle it anymore it's a
butterfinger
ugh i don't like it oh my god it's just
like jesus enough
is there anything in here other than
sugar and glue it just sticks to your
teeth now oh yeah it's it's horrible
yeah horrible it's like he fit into a
mouse trap that had that sugar i know
there's glue traps from mice
uh i'm a twix guy dude twix is
incredible caramel on a cookie over
you know what's funny i had one of those
when they first came out i was like this
is the worst [ __ ] candy bar i've ever
had in my life i [ __ ] hated them and
then years later there was so many
people eating twix i was like maybe i
got a bad one
and i tried it actually liked it
yeah you know what the cookie with the
caramel together is good i'm a gummy
bear i'm a gummy bear guy all that sh
dude i had like those [ __ ] gelatinous
things
it's that's not even doesn't taste like
it's like air
it's like you're eating a [ __ ] chewy
button or something it's like something
that should be on clothes
i don't know why i love them starbursts
i love taffy
well it's just starburst has flavor
that's another thing sticks to your
teeth but like gummy bears there's like
no flavor like i get excited oh a green
one
i'm gonna taste some [ __ ]
uh you know science infused lime here
you know or the orange one and they just
they just sort of like
you can't even bring your teeth together
you do no remember now in laters those
were [ __ ] dude that was like
talking about giving money to a dentist
now and later we're like
i never had one of those
oh now and laters we're horrible for you
all this it's all bad for you dude i had
11 cavities as a kid once 11.
the doctor was just like you know like
like they had like a meeting dude you
were just not brushing your teeth i was
just eating candy and like i would like
rush my teeth at night like real quick
when my mom said to my lucas has a
problem lucas is really addicted to
taffy and candy
and he had a bunch of cavities and they
go dude he's bad like it's bad and now
all his baby teeth are gone so now he's
just like dude i saw him i saw him
sneaking last night into the thing
sneaking last night he just he just
loves candy dude
he loves ca i did too i'm a sucker for
[ __ ] i love candy you had it laying
around you passed it on paul now you're
making me depressed this is this is the
trailer park of your family tree hey all
right the worst thing you're gonna say
about my family is we eat a pack of
twizzlers to [ __ ]
licorice sucks
dude all of that [ __ ] it's like it's
rubber that just doesn't taste like
anything i don't like red vines as much
but a nice twizzler
twizzler with popcorn is a nice combo at
the movies dude
oh dude you can you can take oh and
that's movie popcorn dude there's
nothing better than the first third and
the rest of it it makes you question how
long you're gonna live
like you just wanna die and i [ __ ]
hate like even if you get like a small
it's like just this giant bucket like
they're getting rid of it like i don't
know how much money they make on popcorn
it's like reverse caviar it's just they
cannot give you enough of it yeah like
whatever they give you it's just like i
mean it's insane it's an insane amount
what's grosser or more gross should i
say than getting a hot dog at a movie
or those nachos that's [ __ ] that's
that's cool that's taking it to a whole
it's like just get a [ __ ] pack of
candy and some [ __ ] here's what you do
if you go to the movies you get a small
popcorn your favorite candy and a drink
and you call it a [ __ ] but these guys
put nacho cheese and [ __ ] yeah give me
some jalapenos they got chicken fingers
now pizza hot dogs it's like it's
[ __ ] it's um it's too much i always
overdo it when i go to the movies
i'll get two giant things of [ __ ]
candy
and just get that sugar going and i'm
like oh man i'm getting too hot getting
too high i need the popcorn i got to
bring it down with the salt
and then i finish it off with like you
know what's weird like i like m ms with
the peanuts but those plain m ms dude
like
do nothing for me oh my god it's just
all sugar you have like [ __ ] three of
them three handfuls of those things and
you're just like i i think i got to go
home
my wife loves goobers
so the goobers are just the peanut with
chocolate on them it's just literally
i'm not into raisins man raisins
chocolate covered raisins
oh raisinets dark chocolate raisin
that's not bad
nah
raisins in a dessert it's just like they
shouldn't be together
i don't want to get like racist with
food but they need to be separate but
equal
that's how i am with nuts dude leave
your [ __ ] walnuts out of your banana
bread leave walnuts off a cake oh dude
walnuts with banana bread come on
that's like laurel and hardy i don't
like the crunch
you know i don't want i'm gonna tell you
something paul
as much as italians crush cuisine your
desserts
is are [ __ ] terrible dude you don't
like uh cannolis
no i'm always disappointed like i just
just it doesn't even make it sense that
it's not that good
it's so [ __ ] dry and then the filling
just doesn't do you know maybe if it's a
pistachio one it's all right do it in
those [ __ ] dry ass cookies the other
thing that begins with a bee oh biscotti
yeah yeah biscotti the [ __ ]
all of that [ __ ]
you need a gallon of water to wash it
down
i don't understand how a group of people
can make octopus taste good but you
can't make a [ __ ] cookie it doesn't
make any sense
no the the rainbow cookies are good
there's a couple places i could take you
in the bronx no i'm done with that [ __ ]
i'm done with that [ __ ] everybody oh
dude i got the italian bakery okay you
know what
the rainbow ones aren't the ones that
look like trees are they or my that's a
christmas cookies champagne cookies no
no that's that's the one that looks like
so i'm talking about the one that's
green pink and white and they're very
there's chocolate around them but
they're moist and wet in the middle
they're [ __ ] delicious man
they're delicious
um there's a plate nobody no i got a
sweet tooth like nobody's [ __ ]
business but i'll tell you that i don't
think i've ever ordered dessert in an
italian restaurant
we just got a chocolate uh german cake
german chocolate cake for our
oktoberfest which was uh was pretty
[ __ ] delicious chocolate cake is
german chocolate cake's really good
carrot cake you can go either way can go
either way german [ __ ] is never it's
either great or it's [ __ ] terrible
[Music]
do you like that i just got a gig you
got it huh you like pie oh paul i i can
[ __ ] make a pie i swear to god
where you going pizza cobbler you're
going peach cot you're going a little
pizza whatever the [ __ ] you want
whatever the [ __ ] you want
i'll make a pie crust
okay
that'll make your sicilian eyes water up
and then whatever whatever filling you
got i'll grab a recipe off the internet
and then i'll just add to it i'll improv
off of that like a jazz band
i i just had that recipe egg me on
oh dude i'm i'd love a nice pocket okay
where are you how do you want paul i'll
go first right in your face paul what do
you do
this afternoon in your life scoop a
scoop of vanilla next to it can you make
a cherry pie
never did but i could yeah [ __ ] yeah
oh a peach cobbler sounds good
dude peach cobbler's horrible is it ugh
it tastes like somebody already chewed
it and then puked it up i always feel
like a cow head at first it went through
its first stomach and then it yacked it
into a [ __ ]
plate i hate peach cobbler what about
lemon melon although my sister-in-law
makes a great one
because you know what there is with hers
there's actually the crust
yeah i love the crust dude it always
looks like you dude after two scoops
somebody takes it out it looks like
somebody stepped on it too
like somebody dropped a bowling ball
right in the middle and it's always in
some [ __ ] aluminum [ __ ] tray
i mean low rent dude peach cobbler's low
rent
warm apple pie scoop of vanilla is
jordan
of pies
warm apple with a scoop of vanilla you
just can't [ __ ] with it i'll tell you
why i have a pie that can [ __ ] with that
it's an indiana cream pie
oof the recipe came from i believe
indiana chocolate in it or no no
well you're gonna have this thing dude
it's like heroin it's like [ __ ]
wow it's one of those things like i
don't make the pie because if i make it
i'm going to finish it
i will sit there paul
like i'm eating a bowl of cereal dude
i'm getting starving right now you got
to do this we got to do this
we got to do this we got to do this with
a stick
we got to do this with a stick right the
next time you and i are hanging out yeah
i'm going to make that [ __ ] cream pie
for you here's what we do we go to
dinner either steakhouse or italian
dinner and then we take we do the pie
that you make and then we top it off
with a [ __ ] cube let your irish
german mick [ __ ] friend
handle the dessert i'll let you guys
handle the [ __ ] you know
the entree the second and the main
course by the way if i can do anything
for america i want people to stop
calling the main course the entree
that's french for enter
it's the first thing it's the first ever
yeah i never do stop calling it the
entree i'll tell you one thing and then
i know we got a uh we got to run i got a
[ __ ] early flight tomorrow
when austria
when we were in austria oh [ __ ]
was everything all right my wife just
sent me a text they took off the back of
the [ __ ] driver's side mirror oh no
what happened
oh boy
someone just hit my car and kept driving
oh [ __ ]
they're all right whatever
all right well anyway i was just gonna
say
in austria they have cheese at the end
of everything
so it like cheese closes the dessert so
it's like appetizer then then dinner
then dessert and then the guy came with
cheeses and i go what's this yeah i got
all excited i was like this is oh dude i
remember that that was remember the
greatest [ __ ] places i ever played
and i was so stuffed before i even came
in there and i couldn't stop eating that
food and then he goes oh cheese we do at
the end of everything to and i was like
oh
oh my god what's this like oh amazing
speaking there's a reason why hitler
wanted to get that piece of property
back first
he got greedy paul he just stayed with
that
if all he did was just try to get
austria back
and he led all those other poor innocent
people [ __ ]
he's a [ __ ] dope
he is a dope
somebody's going to animate oh you're
going to you're going out on a limb here
he's a dope and jacksonville's in
disarray because their coach is out in a
[ __ ] hooters bar i mean i mean you
are the king
dude you're like so mesmerizing so you
just go he's a dope i'm like he's a dope
like we're talking about some jerk off
down the street that you don't want
running your website
it's hitler paul
i dude i told you about the way you talk
about hitler like you grew up on the
block with them like what the [ __ ] the
matter with you
like that's what you would say to hitler
no somebody's going to animate that me
and hitler on a boat fishing and it's
going to be quiet and i just why
wouldn't you say hey if you met hitler
why wouldn't you say hey look at that
and then when he looks you hit him with
the [ __ ] bat that's what you should
do because i need because when
somebody's that [ __ ] nuts and does
what he did i need an explanation for a
second i need to find out what he was
thinking
but paul you what for the fascination of
a lunatic mind because if i just said to
him on a boat dude what the [ __ ] were
you doing what are you thinking what's
wrong what's the [ __ ] matter with you
and then wait for an answer what's he
gonna be like i know
[Music]
no i'm always blaming jews like what do
you think he's gonna say yeah yeah i
guess he's not gonna have like yeah i i
i first of all
first of all paul you were on his hit
list
what do you mean oh italy
italy and the greeks you guys were on
his hit list this guy was not stopping
right with what he started with he
considered all
hungarian people
uh
all of those because consider all of
them mongrels you know the greeks kept
them out and they still celebrate that
day it's called ohiode it means no and
that's they said no and then churchill
later on because they they thought
greece was gone then churchill later on
said uh let us not say that uh people
fight like heroes let them say they
fight like greeks i just botched it but
yeah that was they had a big pushback
the greeks there you go no but that was
a great way he said he gave you guys a
shout out so you keep picking his ass so
you'd help him out
the end of the day dude i guarantee you
churchill didn't give a [ __ ] about
greeks
he probably thought he was above you
guys too those [ __ ] english people
i mean
yeah they they think that they're a cut
above
there's a lot of people out there that
they think they're a cut above there's
other [ __ ] groups i can only make fun
of the white ones that do that's how the
game works but you know there's there's
a certain country over there in asia
that gives white people a run for their
money as far as thinking like they're
the chosen ones
and all the other countries out there
paul they have paid the price
they have paid the price but we're not
gonna talk about that paul we're here to
[ __ ] wrap this thing up we're going
to wrap this puppy oh by the way we
didn't talk about i don't know if you
saw it we didn't talk about the tyson
fury wilder fight but can i just say
this oh let's talk oh yes we didn't talk
about is your boston red sox
are advancing shout out to all the
yankee fans who said to me i have fun
getting sweat by tampa
oh well there you go we had a great time
we had a fun time getting swept by tampa
well
here's the thing i enjoyed the fight i
put a 20-foot screen in my backyard i
put a gigantic movie theater screen in
my backyard and we had an oktoberfest
party we had a bonfire and everybody sat
around and watched a [ __ ] movie
theater-sized screen of the fight pretty
clear too
that being said
everybody comparing it people compa i
know they're trying to sell a fight it's
not gottie ward it's not historic it was
a good fight it was a decent fight it
wasn't the [ __ ] people were making i
got to tell you paul it was pretty
sloppy it was one of the uh some of the
ugliest boxing eyes it was just it was
just ham fisted wilder didn't even block
his head man like i'm watching a fight
like the guy wasn't even protecting
himself
and i thought it was cool that fury went
down twice never happened before wilder
got up i thought it was cool that way
but is that how bad boxing has gotten
because ufc has taken over so much that
when you watch a couple of sloppy guys
getting up and down and becomes one of
this girl was it was
just there's a new era in boxing
it's the dad bod era
well you're seeing these guys with dad
bods fighting absolutely shredded
adonises and they're somehow winning
that that latino dude man oh ruiz yeah i
love that guy he [ __ ]
got knocked on his ass just looked back
came up and [ __ ] knocked the dude i
know he lost the next one but like i
don't know as a dad
a little bit of a dead bod there's no
way you get you got to root for the guy
who's got some love handles out there he
looks like you know
he just came walking out of his front yo
you know front porch on your kids knock
it off over there i'll give you a
[ __ ] i'll give you a sunday punch
it's amazing that tyson fury at six foot
nine
yeah can slip a punch this is incredible
well not only that though he got knocked
he gets hit in the face real hard and
comes up
that guy that guy's come up dude when
that one he set up like the undertaker
in that first fight when he was getting
hit on the way down i don't know how he
got up i give him a lot of credit oh no
that guy is like he's like text card
text card but do you get hit in the face
and he'd [ __ ] shake it off he'd smile
he just would keep coming that guy
who those guys are not they're not built
like regular people but i always at this
point though dude knowing what you know
now about cte
like i could i could do without them
cutting to wilder's wife crying
yeah i don't know why i didn't need this
i didn't know i didn't understand why i
needed to see tyson fury figure out what
roads he took to the [ __ ] arena
i mean the fight before it was a great
fight
one of the fights and i'm watching this
guy he gets knocked down for the first
time in his career and they got a split
screen with tyson fury
sitting in like this [ __ ] uh nice
chair
shooting this [ __ ] with some people in
his dressing room it's just like i don't
know i thought that was disrespectful to
the fighters
yeah listen i enjoyed it it went 11
rounds and i had people over that's
always fun and there was some nice shots
that's always fun but to compare it to
gotti ward
to compare it to goddy ward is just this
just wasn't i think that's because of
that youtube kids taking all the money
because i noticed like nine times during
that fight they had to remind me that i
was getting my money's worth
uh yeah yeah you know they kept saying i
mean this is excitement this is what
boxing i mean you can't complain about
this
yeah because
yeah and ufc
dana white in the ufc do a [ __ ]
banger every other weekend where you're
like oh this card's incredible i'm gonna
[ __ ] it's gonna be three and a half
hours of epic and these guys fight tyson
fury and fight once a year so that's the
thing but i did enjoy it um but people
got mad at me they're like that's such a
garbage take paul saying that i go i go
i liked it it was good i did it it's
such a garbage take that you you need to
you need you didn't enjoy it i go i did
enjoy it i enjoyed it very much but it's
not goddy ward it's not historic no
gotti ward was like a was a uh
it was also like
the way the way that they moved and the
way they were punching and everything
like i mean that looked like a [ __ ]
bar room brawl
for like 90 minutes i mean that was like
some [ __ ] like you'd see in a saloon an
old cowboy movie it was just hay makers
wait which one the one the the recent
one yeah the recent one i was just
saying that was just like what the [ __ ]
but then you know gotti ward was just
like dude like how are these two guys
still standing and that was not he was
like
it was like a real rocky apollo like
gotti ward was like like if you saw that
castillo is another one that i always
bring up
that was a great one
yeah evander holyfield versus uh
michael doakes
was a [ __ ] sick fight
just remind me to tell you something
after remind me to tell you something go
ahead no no you no no
after um but you yeah you just said
something but uh i do like that boxing
did have a nice little
night and boxing was like oh it was a
great fight and all that type yeah and
that type of stuff but it was just like
i i could have done without seeing the
dude's wife crying i didn't need to see
that
yeah yeah no um all right man well i
know you got to go i got an early flight
uh
so paul what's your prediction who do
the red sox play now the red sox play
the astros no that you are playing the
astros i think oh no we are playing the
asteroids oh it's the trash can [ __ ]
ball
i both gonna go to home depot and get
some trash cans the one thing about they
know about baseball is its timing and
you guys are flying right now so
anything could happen and it's not a
quick series it's not a wild card or a
three game series so oh i forgot to give
you sh you know what paul did to me last
week
but i do
when uh yeah you know this is coming
paul when i was three you know
looking at and possibly going 4-0
yeah to win my final bet when it was in
and when it was the end of the game and
you knew that tom brady the tom brady
buccaneers were not going to cover you
you [ __ ] texted me there vegas is so
good
that really bugged me you gave a shout
out to a bookie
as your buddy was losing a bet
that's how competitive you are paul that
you got a problem no no no you know i
don't wish that i i didn't wish that on
you
i don't do by the way there was a joy
in that tweet the germans we call that
scheid and freud but look at the word
for
that's what that was paul that's what it
was paul we need to get one thing
straight i don't believe in jinxes
okay huh there's no way that me i didn't
say it was a jinx i was saying sean
freud
is getting pleasure in the misery of
somebody else
the germans are so [ __ ] up they have a
word for it i don't take pleasure in
people that i love having that happen to
paul there was joy in the text there are
certain people that if you were them i
would be happy
who texts why would you text vegas is so
good when i'm losing a bet did you ever
think that maybe i was trying to like be
consoling
no
could be
that's why you're also the guy who like
uh five weeks ago wouldn't shut up about
the yankees in their 13-game winning
streak
and then they lose to the red sox hey
you know i don't give a [ __ ] about
baseball anymore
no it didn't hurt me as much as what i
meant and it didn't me and you have both
been saying that are you really into
this you're not real are you really into
the red sox right now like really
listen
i have two kids under the age of four
i'm not really into anything
i'm getting my ass handed to me by the
bookie i have all i can do to watch a
[ __ ] football game you know what i'm
into paul eight hours [ __ ] sleep now
if i had no [ __ ] personal life i'd
like that's that's all i paul that's
what i did for almost the first 50 years
of my life
bruins yeah
red sox patriots the celtics i would
watch but like you just you just have to
you got to pick you got to pick one or
the other bruins or hockey or celtics
something happens when you get older
though and i think you nailed it married
with kids you can't give a [ __ ] to a
level like you ever see a guy cry in a
bar you ever see a guy scream at a tv in
a bar what the [ __ ] like that i've seen
that and i saw a chiefs fan in new york
doing that
dude he had the whole conspiracy he was
just screaming at the tv oh that's right
give it to him again give it to him
again it's like
wow
i can't i was looking at i was with doug
signia and i was looking like dude this
is how much how long the patriots have
been winning
oh my god
yeah like this guy has literally it's
like watching people that the pandemic
you watch people kind of slowly go crazy
this guy had been losing
just couldn't his team could never win a
super bowl had not won in a super bowl
at that point in since 1970. like that
guy i'm guaranteeing you dude he got
thrown out of the bar
he was in new york city watching chief's
patriots and got thrown out of the bar
he was making so much [ __ ] noise by
himself
wow he just no he got belligerent no no
dude that's like a level i've never me
and you saw the world cup and we saw
that grown man melt when argentina lost
and he was [ __ ] bubbling weeping i've
never given a [ __ ] like that ever that
guy looked like he like the some [ __ ]
doctor said you have six months to live
and that was his last chance to see his
country win the world cup dude if my dog
got hit by a car in front of me and i
saw him like taking his last breaths and
mangled i don't know if i would be i
would be devastated but that guy acted
like that and brazil scored cry if your
dog died in front of you if my dog died
in front of me i would cry but i would
be like dude i would [ __ ] do
everything i could this guy that guy
acted like he just his family got wiped
out
no i understand that part i don't
understand you know dude i can see if a
cat dies who gives a [ __ ] about a cat
hey easy dude that [ __ ] me up man a
song came on
guy's been in my life 16 years man dude
cats are like so transient
like this
just like they're like for their
playboys but people don't know how to
raise a wide caller they're they're not
[ __ ] they're not in it they're not
out of it they like you when they need
something they're [ __ ] [ __ ] dude a
dog
listen a dude a dog you come home man
there's there's no human being that
greets you they greet you like a
four-year-old for the rest of your life
their whole [ __ ] life
they are so [ __ ] excited when you
come home cats don't give a [ __ ] paul
can we do a sketch i'm doing i'm doing
80 stand up right now the difference
dogs and cats can we do a sketch of
coming home and having your wife act
like a dog has snl done that has
somebody done when you come home and
your wife is just like oh my god oh he's
just hugging and kissing you grabbing
your face bill bill had him built a bit
like that on one of my specials about
how my dog greets me versus how my
oh did you yeah then she goes you don't
give a [ __ ] about me i thought so why
don't you act like the [ __ ] dog when
i come home every once in a while oh
that's so funny yeah that
was not the right thing to say in that
moment
i'm fine i just i just make fun of my
wife just to do it she's [ __ ] awesome
yeah me and my wife are going at it so
i'm good oh you are oh yeah i'm going oh
we went at it this morning my wife just
started [ __ ] yelling at me because i
kept going i can't shake this [ __ ]
cold it's not cold but i don't want it
and she always goes maybe it's allergies
every [ __ ] time it's like it's not
[ __ ] allergies
well as you get older your allergies
change it's just like
yeah my wedding i was talking about this
cold that won't [ __ ] go away that
lingers for like two weeks
yeah my wife goes hey there's some
dishes in there if you could do them i'm
not going to do them so i want you to do
them or can you do them i go
oh yeah i'll do them and then i started
watching a [ __ ] show
so i pass out
and you know 6 30 7 o'clock in the
morning i hear dishes going and i go
babe
i said babe i fell asleep last night
i'll do them now i'll do them when i get
up just cause i already [ __ ] did them
yeah i'm with your wife on that you
[ __ ] [ __ ] i fell asleep dude yeah
you're a bump
it's late
excuses that's all i'm hearing paul's
excuses you going to blame your
offensive line now
[Laughter]
paul i wanted to be with you on that one
you know i have your back i wanted to be
with you on that one
uh she wanted them done so she could
come home and wake up dude waking up to
a clean is there anything better waking
up to a clean kitchen dishes are done
everything's spotless
everything is where it's supposed to be
so you don't have to finish the [ __ ]
mistakes of yesterday and then go on a
treasure hunt looking for everything
as you try to make your [ __ ] goddamn
eggs well there's a deeper situation and
the deeper situation is maybe just maybe
sometimes if they put in a little extra
maybe sometimes if they throw a little
[ __ ] more mustard on the fastball
i'll be inclined
to not fall asleep oh we're not talking
about dishes anymore we're not talking
about dishes anymore people i didn't
know where you were going with that
yeah by the way i'm joking my wife does
so dude it's it's the chicken or the egg
they're like hey you know i'd [ __ ]
you know
take care of you a little more maybe if
you did the dishes but then sex becomes
like a reward
i still bit about that you took out the
trash you're a good boy
yeah i know
my i listen i can't my wife [ __ ] did
a party and she did well you can't
complain because you live with her
no but she does where does that get you
no she crushes everything and she's
[ __ ] organized including your [ __ ]
self-esteem come on paul let it out no
she does a lot
she does a lot no eye contact no wine
contact body language she listens she
does a lot she's she's she's got the
[ __ ] snacks out she does the dishes
she [ __ ] cleans and then yes
sometimes
you know i'll come home late and i could
do the one thing but see here's the
thing i don't think it's a and you just
you just you just blew by what you could
have done
no
i think it's not a big deal if i do the
dishes at 7 30 as opposed to doing it at
one in the morning
she doesn't
yeah you're just get it done because
paul she doesn't want to look at those
dirty [ __ ] dishes
and then what's going to happen is the
food's going to dry on them you know
you're doing a half fast i already know
paul i just looking how you dress you're
not good at washing dishes
i know that she probably has to re-wash
at least 30 of them i cannot accept that
in an adult no we have a dishwasher so
we wipe it off and we spray it with the
water and then it goes in a different
you got an automatic pilot is what you
got
yeah it's it's basically unloading and
you can't even rinse off [ __ ] plates
and just stick them in the dishwasher
well i would have to unload the
dishwasher oh
well they're all dried
and organized all the bowls you stack
them up boom all the silverware
wham yeah
i'm wrong it didn't
you didn't because you didn't want to
and she's tired of [ __ ]
walking around with two kids and feeling
like she has three
get off your [ __ ] ass and do the
goddamn dishes it's cause paul it's
because when she she's a type of person
that she's not gonna do the next thing
unless that's done so when she wakes up
in the morning she's not going to do
the lunches right because there's [ __ ]
right there in the sink so she has to
take care of she's off paul didn't do
yeah and i know this paul because i
lived this
yeah was gonna do it i don't know
everything you should do right away yeah
it takes longer to talk about it you
could be everything you could do in ten
minutes you can clean up
i didn't expect to get [ __ ] bullied
on my two [ __ ] friends on my pocket
oh now he's a victim no now he's a
victim
he had a simple job to do he doesn't
take care of it his wife calls him out
on it and now he's getting bullied paul
i'm sorry i always take your side you're
wrong on this one i mean bill's going
and then you got the greek freak popping
in i mean [ __ ] i'm gonna go take the
garbage out right after this podcast you
should
i cannot handle living with an adult
that's like a [ __ ] slob it's just
like definitely not a slob i'm clean i'm
definitely not a slob
i'm not saying you don't have your
sneaker collection organized if it's
something you care about i'm sure your
cigars are lined up nicely in your
humidor and you have your bottle
colognes alphabetized i'm talking about
the mainstream areas
the bathroom the kitchen
paul you can see it in your eyes you can
see in your eyes paul no i mean i got a
cleaning lady yeah
yeah yeah yeah
yeah your heart's jake cutler you know
you got all the potential i just don't
feel like you want to play in this city
anymore
[Music]
it's inexplicable yeah if i you know
what you're right if i put it on other
things the way i do my career and life
and kids and being a dad i need to do
that you know what fine i could admit
that
it took a while but okay we'll give you
that we could all get better we could
all be better [ __ ] people paul you
really could admit you argued it and at
some point you said you were being
bullied i can't remember it was just
like i thought at one point i was going
to get cancelled
all right
that is the uh that is the show guys so
we gave you two hours
you know you could be cleaner i could be
more easygoing you know what i mean
that's why this podcast works paul
together we make one perfect bald man
and speaking of laughs
speaking of that get uh
get all of the uh podcasts on spotify
itunes wherever you get your podcast
check out obviously monday morning
podcast diversity effect go to the
youtube channel guys
october 22nd i am doing my first theater
the wilba the wilba kid i'm going to be
there october 22nd friday night tickets
are going i hope to see you guys there
oh you're going to crush it up there i
can't wait to get up there so um there
you go i can't wait to watch you still
bring up eli manning and ignore that the
yankees just [ __ ] lost again in the
playoffs to the red sox i'm waiting for
that
you know you're still doing your eli
joke you know you are i'm not you are no
i'm not you will you get back you're
gonna get backed into a corner you're
gonna dust it off no no no one more time
little [ __ ] vaseline on the hat
you're gonna [ __ ] throw it right over
there
shaking off the catcher
uh
all right guys
i'm coming with the
gas till next week man we're out of here
thank you guys so much for listening
enjoy our football picks on our bet mgm
edition talk to you guys all right we'll
see
[Music]
you